ausgesetzt in einem Zimmer in Berlin
kämpfen zwei Kandidaten 24 Türchen ums
Überleben sie treten an um den knossi
Adventskalender zu
bewerten Scheiße Mann nicht zu kotzen
und die besten Alge Sorten
herauszufinden Alge Alge Alge Alge Alge
Bo energ drin ich bin voll müde oh ja
das könnte natürlich sein ich weiß es
nicht ich weiß nicht mal wie man den da
rauskriegt der ist der ist sehr
schwer sorry m oh mein Gott ein
originalknossi
Autogramm kannst Du Dich jetzt mal
kurz ja natürlich sind wir schon drin
das war keine Begrüßung und nicht gihr
gibt keine Begrüßung keine Begrüßung
hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne und
euer also ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt
Timo weißt du wie viele Sorten es schon
von Alge gibt ich dachte Alge hat so
drei Sorten ja dachte ich auch glaube
das ist extra für diesen Kalender kannst
du hinten Vorlesen was drauf steht der
EE Adventskalender ein Adventskalender
ganz nach König knossis Geschmack für
jeden Tag im Advent haben wir für dich
eine neue Probe entwickelt die du dir
abends nach dem Feierabend gönnen kannst
aber wichtig nach dem Feierabend auch
von einigen unserer vorhandenen Sorten
haben wir ein Probefläschchen mit
reingelegt hast du richtig Bock ich bin
hyped ja ich bin dabei bereit ich habe
viel gearbeitet heute also nach meinem
Feierabend kann ich mir jetzt hier darf
du dir heute was gönnen ja ich habe auch
Bock hast auch Bock ja ich ja weiß ich
nicht jetzt wo ich gesehen habe dass da
so halt wirklich denk so an berenen Saur
Apfel und so ein Scheiß ja trip down the
memory lane ist doch
geil wie wie gehen wir vor trinken wir
immer jeder ein abwechsel ganzen oder
wie wird erstmal appreciaten wir ja die
sind cool die shotgläser S ein bisschen
dirty aus oder seh dirty aus ich ge sie
kurz mal ausspien Bo hast aber hast du
ihn rausgestellt der ist voll schön kalt
ja weil ich ja schon dachte dass da halt
Alkohol drin sein du bist so smart okay
wir müssen mal jetzt ganz kurz hier mal
loslegen oder was bevor wir jetzt noch
zu oft Alge und knossi sagen dieses
Video ist nicht gesponser und jetzt alle
dieses vide ist nicht gesponser aber ich
habe den Kalender von knossi zugeschickt
bekommen weil auch knossi mein bester
Freund ist genauso wie Sally ich als
beste Freundin von Sally habe natürlich
auch einen Brief bekommen so seid ihr
dieser Kalender was hat er gekostet mal
du bringst mich völlig aus dem Konzept
ich bin ein nur hier und lass mich hier
durchführen jetzt nur zum Probieren hier
der Kalender kostet
12999 und das macht 5,40 pro Türchen 540
pro Türchen ja was hältst du von dem
Preis schon amtlich muss ich sagen ne
hier sch l nicht rausfallen ich bin weg
tschüss wir gehen rein Leute wir gehen
rein so sieht Türchen bzw FL Nummer 1
aus und hier kleines Ding wo drauf steht
hier abziehen und dann wollen wir noch
mal schauen was ich hier natürlich in
ein verwirkt türkisch Pepper ach geil
okay jetzt check ich ah dann revealt man
es D sieht man es nicht sofort cool das
ist cool knossi Nummer eins das wird
aufregend heute ich bin gespannt ob da
was los ist was passiert noch gar nicht
ready für den für den flavor boah das
riecht wie nee ne nee mein Vater immer
zum uso uso ja ich trink was trinkst
denn so ist das eine probiermenge das
ist ja nichts
24 stimmt ich sehe uns später auch schon
zur Weinbar laufen machen wir noch ein
Wein oder noch ein absack denn tschüss
wird eine lange
nachtp boah schon strong so brauchen wir
d heute hier h aber so berenind oder SAS
was du verglichen hast das schmeckt
jetzt nicht so doll das hat 40% das hat
40 40% ja guck doch so schmeckt mich
auch schmeckt richtig strong ist darin
also zwei ganze Shots sind immer in den
Flaschen
drin Türchen Nummer
2 ihr dürft zuerst
lesen Blutorange jutu juu das jutu
nicht tauche ein in die fruchtige Welt
des fruchtlikörs ja jetzt haben wir
fruchtigen gehen wir rein der schmeckt
wie ja ist gut ja s vi stimmt stimmt
stimmt stimmt mir genauo
viel riech mal riech mal riecht wie wie
Kalka red ja
ach und es schmeckt genauso es schmeckt
genauso aber viel besser als davor Taus
mal geiler guck mal den Unterschied wenn
ich
einchke und Timo einschink Türchen
Nummer 3 jetzt bist du dran oh wir
müssen raten was glaubst du was das für
ein Geschmack ist Apple Apple Sau Apple
ich w auch sagen ich sag
Kiwi das einzig grüne was
mir grüne Apfel du hast gewonnen du
kriegst den Preis so
viele ich auch ein ein echter
conissur sch V bisschen weiter ob so
bisschen so kemil mäßig aus
zusammenohl
geil geil das schmeißt mich sofort
zurück schon bisschen Trauma ins
scheuenfest
[Musik]
ach so sollten wir die vielleicht
bewerten ich hab mal gesagt wie ich
finde gibt kein Punktesystem damit die
Leute sich an unserem Punktesystem okay
doch lass Punktesystem einf fin ich gut
von Krone wie viel Kronen bekommt das
ein bis F ein maximal ein ich würde zwei
Kronen geben anderthalbhalb Kronen Treff
uns in Mitte Blutorange drei auf jeden
Fall wür ich oh da bin ich dabei bist du
dabei ja
hüneapfel vier eiglich auch nicht aber
schon deutlich besser als der Blutorange
okay 3,9 Kronen t Nummer vi ach erraten
was ist Bubblegum wild berry irgendwie
so gesagt so wildberry l mäßig aber
stimmt das wird nicht kN Dings reinpackt
Bubblegum ist schon eher wahrscheinlich
ich gehe auf
whiteberry
himberry so weit entfernt oh ich habe
von Hassan hier noch über Stroh Leute
ich hab Hamster ich hab noch nie gesagt
jetzt sage
ich ich habe auch Haare von Hass ich bin
richtig voll dies richtig gut
eingeschenkt zur
[Musik]
m null null null null kommull das ist
jetzt nicht super geil aber es ist so
süß und kann man gut trinken das him ist
nicht gut umgesetzt finde ich schon
finde ich schon wie viel gibst würdest
du geben ich woll drei eigentlich sagen
ja ich
e D und null manchmal kann man sich
einfach nicht in der Mitte treffen null
null das wird jetzt schwierig oh bitte
nicht so K Nummer
5 wir hab nicht wir nicht geraten nein
wir haben nicht
geraten ich sag London
dryin und du Dr
London knappe Kiste ja gut können nicht
pur trinken
doch morgen wir uns Küche aus morgen
küchenermin ich hoffe wir haben Kater W
glaub ich das worst cas Senario einfach
da wier Z bis unendlich viele Stunden
trat sein mit einem Kater ist unser
dritter küchentermin küchenaussuchen
dauert lange das kann do nicht sein
London
dryinit da merkt auf jeden Fall wenn es
gleich hochgedreht ist
ne gut also kein schlecht sch nicht nach
schlechtenin oder okay das ach so
Bewertung ich vergess mal die wichtig
jetzt ultra schwer zu bewerten keine
Ahnung geschmacklich jetzt ist halt
einfach mal zwei drei dre komm soll hier
nimm drei drei komm wir geben dir drei
drei next one weißt du was das nächste
Türchen ist Nikolaus und das ist dir
wichtig das ist wichtig oh ich du bist
wirklich ohne Scheiß nee das wird schon
kein das wird kein Nikolaus Geschmack
sein Nummer se ach rate was ist das für
ein Flav s sieht original wieder aus wie
unsere himbell ich sag regret das ist
Zim Wassermelone wie dumm dashalb hätte
man drauf kommen können wie ist das
Konzept angedacht von
junge
Timo das ist
SH sorry sorry sorry
SH oh das riecht original wie Zahnpasta
Leute so kinderzahnp
kinderzahnp ne ist nicht aber ich bin
auch kein Fan von wassermelonengeschmack
also ich bin erstmal enttäuscht dass
Nikolaus einfach so Wassermelone drin
ist die sommerlichste Frucht die es gibt
das ist richtiger
mittelfingeress ich f schon okay was
hättest du denn erwet Nikolaus ich meine
Getränke Zimt glühweineschmack ein so
weinach Bratapfel ich gib zwei was gibst
du ich
gebe zwei Türchen Nummer s oh ich sag
ich weiß es ich weiß es ich weiß es ich
weiß es was sagst du ich sag Zuckerwatte
ich sag bubblegumg das hast du schon mal
gesagt Pink
Grapefruit hör auf
jetzt lst auch mich einschenken weiß ich
nicht weil du auf immer ist einer dran
riecht sehr geil isotonischen
sportdink let's
go stark auch wieder extrem stark
Grapefruit 17,5 okay echt ich hätte auch
eher gesagt in die 40er Richtung do
gesagt vier echten wir denön wir einfach
mal hier will wie Wolf Nummer Wodka sage
ich Wodka das wä so geisteskrank ne
Wodka wür ich jetzt direkt brechen ich
sag sieht schon sehr klar aus sieht
schon sehr sehr klar
nur Wasser gerade
ein so das ist
einches geil Zwischenwasser gibt so
viele klare Schnäpse ja Obstler sage ich
super marlikör gar nicht so weit weg mit
Obstler davon kannst du mal be davon
vorsichtig das doch das ist richtiger
schnbis Hardcore
shit ein ne z TR irwie rein ja das ma
die so eine Farbe h also die dachten
wirklich bei der bei den Fotos machen
dachten sie das es sieht anders aus
Türchen Nummer ne Türchen Nummer 9 ist
mein lieblingstürchen denn das ist meine
Geburtstag
lieblingszah ich dachte s w lieblingsah
nein neun natürlich li
gelb blau Schlumpf ja
Jaen ich sag Minze die Spannung steigt
eisminze drei Tage wach ich bin drei
Tage wach Timo sorry
o so schön nach oben e muss man unten
anfangen dann langsam hochziehen oh ist
gut fünf fünf ich habe an meinem Daumen
gelutscht fer oder
wie schmeckt original wie das
Lutschbonbon ja ein Benger ist ein
Benger EE eismünze das ist seine
Originalmarke
der Moment auf den wir alle so lange
gewartet haben okay die hat auf jeden
Fall die
potenzialümer Nummer Karamel bin
eigentlich starker Karamell Liebhaber
aber soll sagen was du denkst und
austringen hier ich habe l gesagt was
ich gedacht habe ich bin Fan von Karamel
ich habe gesagt Karamel ja und dann hast
du gesagt ach so ich ich habe kurz über
Karamel geredet aber das ist
bewusst versteh gar nicht ich habe
gesagt D bin ich ausg dass Karamel drin
ist we mag ich eigentlich eigentlich
aber eher in Eis mag ich das ich war
noch nicht soeit dass ich selber raten
muss Karamell ist eine sehr gute Wahl
ich sage aber eher süß wie
honis fate
Limette das schmeckt original wie Mate
ohne Kohlensäure das schmeckt echt wie
Mate schmeckt wie Mate ohne Kohlensäure
ber ber ber schmeckt wie eine wodg m ja
abgestandene schckt halt dadurch dass
man nicht den geilen Sprudel hat und so
qu quadro klar ist eine vier wir sind
bei Nummer ich sag Kirche Kirche okay
ich sag Pflaume Kirche Vers Pflaume Alge
Cranberry das hätte dann z.B an Nikolaus
drin sein können wer denkt denn am
sechsten Türchen an Wassermelone was ist
denn bei euch los wie kann man so dumm
sein wie ich auch wirklich wie kann man
so dumm sein Cranberry ist
weihnachtlicher
stoppowowow jetzt beruhigen wir uns
mal
oh sauer geil fin geil man merkt schon
irgendwie diese Alge Sachen sch besser
mir liebe reingeflossen and sind so
gefühlt so no den berär RA Ansage an
knossi was labert ich möchte schon immer
eine Popup Bar mal aufmachen wo ich drei
Cocktails die ballern machen kann
Sponsor be
Alge geile Idee das Urin ich s Urin kame
nein ich s Atomic enery ich Zitrone
da hätte man noch drauf kommen
können eine Woche
wach nicht so strong ja hätte saurer
sein können ne maraku eigentlich voll so
bisschen der der Punch irgendwie so sin
von Sauer kleiner Kick noch so Halbzeit
haben wir erreicht kommen wir zur
zweiten Hälfte weiß gar nicht mehr was
ich dazu noch sagen soll zurück zu dir
in Studio B schon beschwipst nee ich bin
noch gar nicht und du schon bisschen
doch du schon na dann geht's weiter mal
klaren
hinterheren 13 Wodka du gehst wieder
Wodka ich sag dass ist diesmal uso ne
uso ist es nicht aber komm wollen wir
erst probieren und
dann guter
Twist auf
dich Zuckerwatte ich hätte als erstes
Haselnuss gesagt aber oh ja doch stimmt
auch könnte auch sein wir haben
Haselnuss und Zuckerwatte und es ist
Marille schon wieder Marille Marille
spirituoseosetig warm KST das wenn so
warm runtergt das ist so ein vatterer
bringt den Schnaps raus
Schnaps mit
Belg der muss erstmal atmen ich wei es
kleine
apothekenjunge
ja junge es ist der apothekenjunge ja es
ist glaube ich eine Kirsche diesmal ich
glaub johannesbär ich sag
apothekenkirsche ihr seht es bevor uns
white
berryry wenn white Berry schon vor dir
ist dann hast du es nicht erkannt aber
stimmt jetzt W man weiß white Berry ja
ist ja stimmt 15
orange hallo oh
sorry die Leute denken doch ich habe ich
habe ein Schatten
komplett orange boah ja oh es schmeckt
wie merinda das war immer die polnische
Fanta die ich dort getrunken habe und es
ist Multi Multi ah Multivitamin okay s
übelst nicht gut im Raten von
geschmckern nee versuchen wir
weiter man muss dur nur durch Üben wird
man besser Willenskraft wie Wolf mus die
glö zusammen machen und dann kannst
duich so h auf du klebst hier alles voll
warum hst du die Gläser so voll wir
trinken fasttail
barer Lemon ich sag Dings Gin
mitin mos mos
genau m ich sag du sagst mos ich sag
mosc
mu Nummer 17 das wird doch spannend Urin
nachdem man ganz viel Wasser getrunken
hat
che scheiße
man an apfellör das ist uso das ist uso
ja aber das ist ja die Zutat aber den
Apfel den schmeckt man nicht der ist
verloren gegangen Nummer 18 boah wir
sind erst bei Nummer 18
nee und wir haben wieder mal Kirsche
oder apothekenjunge Stopp Stopp Z
wohlees kürche uso war zu stark noch
drin
Erdbeer jetzt echt voll doll nach Anus
nicht euer Ernst hier oder und die
Lösung ist Red beer uso redbeer uso was
ist ein Red beer roter Bär lang keine
Punkte we gegeben das ist hier komplett
lost on the way jetzt ist nur noch
durchkommen jetzt geht nur nochs
durchkommen Willenskraft Willenskraft 19
Bo bin ich froh wenn da eine zwei vorne
ist ne heißt dass man kurz vom Ende ist
e wenn ich weg bin bin ich weg
Chat
sch ich habe schmeck nichts stark ist
hat gerade so dolle nach spiritose
geschppert ich würde sagen spiritose mit
einem Hauch von Orange Rose so ein
bisschen blumig habe ich das Gefühl
rababa Gin ja ja dieses blumige kommt
von
rababa so Leute wir sind jetzt
angekommen bei
der ich das an
dich okay
Leute
so einmal numero 20 sehr schön ich ma
mal auf WE ist nicht mehr anwesend sehr
holzig ich schen das jetzt einfach mal
nur mir ein weil ich bin ja ganz
alleine da kommt sie da kommt sie Bo ne
boah das ist ich glaub aber jetzt geht
abwärts
Leute
alternuss gut oder schlecht du sollst
probieren ich mussck reagierst Haselnuss
Hasel warte warte warte warte warte
warte cremige Haselnuss und die Lösung
ist f Nuss
Schokolikör F mich wie bei König der
löfen ewigen
Kreis fand ich gut auch gut ja fand ich
auch gut hatte wirklich Haselnuss aber
stimmt es hatte eher so ein ferero
Küsschen hass ich du magst aber doch
Nutella ja du magst Haselnüsse Nutella
mit Haselnüssen ich glaub ich Kü
probiert ist egal oder wir gehen rein
Nummer 21 hoffentlich nicht ranzig also
ja das muss ein Sahnelikör sein ja
100% ganz bisschen few
Baileys wow geil man ist das nicht viel
zu stark ne ich wie so ein Proteinshake
Geschmack sag ich sag Kaffee Vanille
Haselnuss
Haselnuss Haselnuss woll wir den mal
raten nach den ganzen s die wir nicht
geratet haben den fand ich jetzt gut
fand ich für F das war toll Nummer 22
Kirche kurze Geschmack Geruchsprobe oh
nee Kräuter nee Jägermeister 100% 100%
sag Jägermeister Jägermeister ich sag
Zimt ich sag Kräuterlikör
Kräuterlikör let's go geil ist dieser
Typ kräu ich von auf kräu gegangen bin
okay wir sind angekommen eins vor
Christmas das vorletzte Türchen an
dieser Stelle fragen euch eure
Familienmitglieder hey was ist los in
letzter Zeit warst du ab immer so
komisch drauf also wirklich jedes Mal
zum Feierabend wirktest du irgendwie
komisch du bist nach Hause gekommen bist
dann zu deinem Kalender und ab dann
haben wir dich irgendwie gar nicht mehr
gesehen irgendwie finden wir auch
überall in deiner Wohnung kleine
Flaschen hast du ein Problem
Intervention dann kommt eine
Intervention dann sagst du okay nur noch
morgen und dann höre ich auf aber mal
gucken was der Tag heute bring h ich
Bailey ist jetzt aber wirklich aber
wirklich simti oder irgend so Müll
gerade
identifizieren ich sag Kaffee Kaffee
Scheiße ja mann Sahnelikör nouer nou oh
mein got ich weiß es ich weiß es sein
Original algemix Drink ja tüchen Nummer
24 wir haben uns durch die Tage
getrunken es ist Weihnachten man hat
alles mit der Familie erlebt was man
erleben konnte dann zieht man sich
zurück in sein
Kinderzimmer Kind die Pudel ganz schon
drauf trinken feiern
tanzen
ne da steht voll viel eige extreme
[Applaus]
S mit muss großen machen als Abschluss
großen den ganzen rein hab
durchgekämpft was fandest du gut an
diesem Kalender ich fand diese Schilder
cool dass man das so abziehen konnte und
dann es exposed wurde welcher Geschmack
das ist dass man darus wie so ein
Ratespiel machen kann ja und seh
unterschiedlich breit aufgestellt viele
flavors das kann man dem nicht
abstreiten viele schlechte viele gute
okay nee ich muss auch sagen ich bin
schon länger am überlegen einen eigenen
Adventskalender zu machen und ich würde
nicht lügen wenn ich schon mal in die
Richtung nicht was gedacht hätte
deswegen weiß ich wie teuer die
Produktionskosten sind von diesen
Flaschen 24 verschiedene Geschmäcker mit
den zwei Gläsern und so man glaubt es
nicht aber es kommen halt viele Kosten
zusammen und dann gibt's noch den
Produzenten und knossi muss noch was
kriegen da muss noch der Verpacker was
kriegen so ich kann mir
schnell genau und es ist schwer so ein
Kalender dann noch günstiger zu bekommen
wie viel hat gekostet 129
129 das Ding ist wenn man halt knossi
Fan ist dann hol man sich den so dann
ist es halt irgendwie funny wenn es aber
darum geht z.B so ein Schnaps Kalender
zu verschicken verschenken zu wollen
dann würde ich halt lieber ein Wodka
kaufen und immer so verschiedene
infusions machen weiß du und dann so das
ist mit Sim das ist mit das habe ich
also dann so selbst gemacht und dann
kommst du halt günstiger weg aber es ist
halt es ist ein Fanartikel ne Cheers
rein in die Rüstung und jetzt kommt der
Song
Alge al al al erstaunlich lecker der
bester schön Sau der ist aber echt
wirklich extrem sauer irgendwie witzig
weil er so sauer ist ich fin auch geil
tschüss tschüssowski knoss wirklich
ne lass mal zusammen eine cocktailb
aufmachen also so für einen Tag dein
Management rede mit mein Management und
dann mit Timo und dann wieder mit dein
Management tschüss